[Applause]
okay here are the questions people are
wanting to know answers to what why do
we need a space for us when we have NASA
yes if you missed it Trump sent out Mike
Pence to announce the spate Mike Pence
does not seem like a space guy but he's
in charge of space force a sixth branch
of the armed service that Trump wants he
said it was separate but equal' he said
that the bots I couldn't help notice met
space force opinions what do you think
congressman you're he trumped the dodge
the draft five times to avoid serving in
in Vietnam but maybe if he could have
been a space cadet Joe Biden had the
moon shot as vice presidents they wanted
to have something equivalent very vice
president but is there is there anything
to the fact that space is different than
it was twenty thirty years ago I mean it
is it is becoming a place where
countries will guess as the North Pole
is a place where countries didn't use it
could use to contend for power and now
they will be there I mean we do have to
invest in space the Air Force does that
yeah the Air Force and we should do more
of it I don't know that we need a space
force I think it's just something you
saw on TV I mean it sounds like a sitcom
doesn't it sound but the most important
thing to know about it is and I think
the congressman will agree with this is
it's not going to happen
[Applause]
it's not up the truck it's up to him it
has to be voted on by Congress and this
is at the moment the beginning down
payment on it is eight billion dollars
that you don't have it's it's an
increase in the deficit by another eight
billion dollars it would never get
through as it is now well they ran up a
trillion with the tax cut so eight
billion would be nothing if they wanted
to do it yeah but when he speaker of the
house next year he's not gonna like no
I'm not gonna run for Speaker myself but
I do think it's time for a new
generation of leadership in our party
we'll see we'll see what happens okay
Lawrence what do you say to people who
claim MSNBC is just a liberal version of
Fox News oh [ __ ] we work with facts
really is I cede back the balance of my
time
right steven pinker how do you fight a
political party that's winning with a
platform of hate and fear well it didn't
identify which one I do the Democrats
should take ownership of policies that
have worked like the Environmental
Protection Agency which has reduced air
pollution by sixty percent
they don't brag very well they don't
they really don't Democrats do not brag
well yeah like really have reduced
poverty and if Trump has really shown us
the people in this country gonna hold it
against you when you brag and the debate
and this midterm election season you
know with all due respect shouldn't be
about Nancy Pelosi right like there is a
generational discussion to be had among
Democrats if they win back power if they
don't
however the it should be about ideas if
Democrats are moving more to the left on
health care issues they should be out
there talking about Medicare for all or
why they don't agree with that or how
you will defend the EPA and instead you
have this constant either reaction to
what the president is to
or it becomes about whoever the
boogeyman is at the moment whether that
was Hillary Clinton or damn totally
right and here in California where you
have these very competitive
congressional races that's again I mean
and the LA Times we wrote that story you
know what are people saying about Nancy
Pelosi because it is news but the
candidates get lost in that and that
doesn't really help any voters try to
distinguish what the ideas you are
actually fighting for you know the
Democrats position on Trump have you
have you heard this have we mentioned a
few times we get it we get the Democrats
are opposed to Trump we got to start
talking about what we're gonna do you
know what we're gonna do for this
country I mean yeah I wouldn't
completely hold up on a rat talking
trunk there's a lot to be said about we
hate Trump and he's a traitor
you know I mean he did sell this country
out to another country I would hope I
would hope one political party could
make that a bit of an issue he won't
stop saying it but we've got to start
talking about what we're gonna do today
you've got bragging about what you do is
good so we have to teach you how to grab
your nuts once in a while well that
would be cultural appropriation
[Applause]
DL Hughley do you think it's best for
black celebrities to shun Trump or meet
an attempt to reason with him I've just
never said what - black - black people
are photo ops like that like he's never
when he wants to talk like he wants to
talk to athletes actors and comedians
about the problems and a black me why
don't he just talk to David Blaine and
make them all disappear it's like it's
like he never like he's never serious
about what he does and I think that I've
never seen a black person meet with him
who got a result other than black people
being angry with him and in a picture so
I think he's I think there's any
credible and I think no of course not
okay he sold us out and now she wants to
buy the tech yeah I sold you out here's
how written by the guy who killed Jay
you so I say that for me was that
President Trump was eating paper which
you know right eating paper yeah whether
you hide secrets or you maybe you just
needs paper what the hell was that you
know I think it was a fit of anger yeah
he says that his regular diet yeah
she says he had a recording of him
saying the n-word lately like that black
people not gonna be shocked by that at
all no but I think it's also funny that
Trump accused Obama and Comey member of
secretly taping him but who did actually
see ya taping it that people trusted
Omarosa and Michael : yeah and that's
what we know about it and that and that
soccer ball from Putin has a mic in
thank you very much